Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
new spider-man no way home video for all the new
spider-man suit previews in the first looks they
were just releasing there were a lot of them and
spider-man took the black way faster than i ever
expected jon snow would be proud as he is also now
a marvel character in the eternals movie there's a
whole bunch of easter eggs here we'll break it all
down i'll be doing spider-man and venom videos all
year so be sure to subscribe to get those videos
we're doing a giveaway for disney plus memberships
too all you have to do to enter is just be a
subscriber and post your favorite new spider-man
suit from the movie in the comments so if you
didn't see the news though because the movie
spider-man no way home was originally supposed
to come out this summer a lot of the toy stuff was
all queued up to be released real soon and while
they delayed the marvel phase 4 movies in the sony
spider-man movies a bunch the toy people did not
delay any of the toy reveals so that's how we know
about all these new suits what they look like and
what all the other characters look like because
some of the other characters got costume changes
as well i'll start with the actual new suits and
the easter eggs there then i'll talk about the
other new stuff like the new doctor strange
costume wong's new costume which apparently
he bought with his money he earned during his
mortal kombat tournament in the shangshi trailer
with the abomination even though it kind of seems
like he gets his ass handed to him in that movie
thank you definitely gonna leave a mark
but i guess he has to earn that sandwich
money somehow i guess because apparently being
a sorcerer in the mcu doesn't pay very well but
there are three count them three new spider-man
suits in the movie that we know about the first
big new spider-man suit is the black and gold suit
which they're just calling the black and gold suit
even though it's mostly black which is some gold
highlights i think they're calling it the black
and gold suit so that when they finally put him in
the venom symbiote some day later after he crosses
over with venom they'll call that the black suit
so they're just saving that black name for later
and that is comic book accurate the black suit
was historically first referred to as the alien
costume because he got it during the 1980s secret
wars event then he got rid of it and they did
the big venom origin story it became the symbiote
suit because that's when they introduced the venom
character and kind of retconned the suit but also
after that spider-man then later wore a non-living
cloth version of the symbiote costume and that
one was just referred to as the black costume
and if you zoom in enhance on it you can actually
see this exposed integrated gold circuitry and
circuit patterns so even though the previews
and first looks don't have specifics on what
all of the new suit functions are there are some
visual cues here this might be a suit that he uses
against people like electro because it seems way
more tech based way more cyberpunk than the other
new suits overall it looks kind of like they
combine visual elements of his mcu spider-man
basic logo design like the basic suit design with
some of the visual cues from the spider-man armor
mark ii in the anti-shock costumes from the comics
and at least the concept of the anti-awk costume
from the spider-man ps4 game just taking
some of those black and yellow highlights
from the spider armor mark ii maybe some of the
anti-shock functionality for fighting electro
i don't know if this suit actually has anything
to do with the doctor octopus fight scenes in the
movie because we know he'll be fighting doctor
octopus but you all remember the anti-aux suit
from the end of spider-man ps4 the original
spider armor mark ii was built to replace
his lost spidey sense abilities temporarily
and just give him a measure of bulletproofing
as in keeping with tradition usually the new suits
are created because the last suit either gets
destroyed or it's ineffective against whoever the
new villains are and we know a little bit about
some of the new villains a lot of the sinister
six stuff is going on during the film there's
some minor differences between the funko designs
here and the marvel legends designs in the suit
the gauntlets the web shooters and the fingers all
look red and the marvel legends design that just
might be something that the toy people changed on
their own adding the red elements and if you look
at the big lego set there is a scene that they
depict with the gold suit where he's fighting
michael keaton's vulture character and they call
it like a drone fight with this gold looking drone
the way they're depicting this too the black
and gold suit has gold webbing but i don't know
if that's just for the toys or if there's actual
gold webbing in the movie because can you imagine
how expensive it would be for peter parker to
make that gold web fluid even though iron man
left him access to all of his technology and his
resources you have to imagine pepper potts who's
still the ceo of stark industries seeing the
balance sheet for the expenses that month but
this drone attack scene with vulture is not
supposed to be in the movie i don't know if
michael keaton's vulture is actually in the movie
originally i thought that he was but i haven't
seen a whole lot of plot synopsis that mention him
mostly just the doctor octopus and electro stuff
and all the rumors about other sinister six
villains from the tobey maguire spider-man movies
also there's all the stuff happening on loki with
them messing with the timeline in the multiverse
so we'll see how much of the connection there is
there but i believe the idea is that at some point
during spider-man no way home they will have a
moment where they acknowledge a villain team up
but that might not happen till the very end of
the film like a post-credits scene but it seems
like there's so much sinister six energy in this
movie so once they drop that first trailer we'll
see just how quickly they run to sinister six
during the film the second brand new spider-man
suit they're just calling the integrated suit
and it's actually the suit that most people were
posting on social media the past day or so you
probably saw it in your feed at some point and
it looks very familiar because it looks like a
version of the iron spider suit from avengers
infinity war in avengers end game but the really
cool reason why it's called the integrated suit as
you'll see from this first look here is because
doctor strange has integrated his magic with it
that's right peter parker you're a wizard now make
all the harry potter jokes and you joke but this
is actually based on some cool concept art that
they didn't use from avengers infinity war and
alternate iron spider suit designs the cool iron
mage deleted scenes also from avengers infinity
war where doctor strange combined his magic with
the aya vaga moto in iron man's nano armor and
a really big deep cut from the iron man what-if
comics where tony stark became a version of the
sorcerer's supreme but instead of learning all
the spells the traditional way reading the books
reciting incantations casting spells that way
that version of tony stark sorcerer supreme
built enchantments into a new iron man suit and
integrated the casting of spells and incantations
into the suits ai and software so he automated
the casting of spells so that he wouldn't have
to speak the words of the incantations and could
just cast spells on the fly like iron man would
normally use his weapons in a regular fight so
this spider-man suit actually looks like a version
of the infinity war iron spider suit that he's
just taken and upgraded even more with the help
of doctor strange like at some point after the end
of spider-man far from home when he gets doxed by
mysterio and j jonah jameson he finds a way to
grab the iron spider armor from aunt may's house
then upgrades it with doctor strange's help and
i'm assuming based on what's going on here with
the spell animations that he's got magic enhanced
web shooters and some additional protections like
a magical shield boosting his strength and
durability in the suit the overall design
of the suit with the extra gold highlights is
based on some of these alternate infinity war
concept art designs from the iron spider suit
they iterated with a ton of different versions
of the iron spider suit before landing on the
one that was actually in the movie so if the
new integrated suit looks familiar that's why
the third new suit is what they're actually
calling the upgraded suit and it's actually just a
slightly different iteration of the new jack kirby
looking suit from the end of spider-man far from
home you all probably remember seeing pictures of
this when they were filming the movie last year
tom holland was posting pictures of this himself
on his instagram and most people actually just
assumed that this was the exact same suit from
far from home but if you notice there's a small
difference here if you look down around the waist
they've actually gotten rid of that black band
element and it looks more like this the waist
actually looks way more like toby maguire's
spider-man costume now there are probably a lot
of other upgrades that he makes to this suit but
visually that's just the most notable change that
you can spot here then they have this big sanctum
set which they depict with a bunch of different
action scenes obviously doctor strange is a big
character in the film and a lot of the early
previews that we got like the official images of
them breaking into that run down looking place
is the actual sanctum so no surprise
there'll probably be a big action set piece
inside the sanctum just like we saw during the
original doctor strange movie and as crazy as
some of these action scenes are i'm sure he will
probably break half of the stuff that thor broke
just walking in to have a conversation with
doctor strange there are a bunch of different
scenes that they depict during this big playset
so some of these probably won't be in the movie
because they do a lot of this stuff just for the
toys i don't know if the actual scorpion mech is
in the movie but michael mando was teasing that
he was coming back as scorpion sometime pretty
soon there's even a small depiction of the clocal
levitation getting its own action scene separately
following spider-man around here there's some kind
of tentacles coming out of a mystery chest here
i'm sure that there'll be some comedic scenes
with spider-man mj and ned lee's walking around
the sanctum just getting into all kinds
of stuff they're not supposed to get into
i also don't know if this mysterio fight scene
with the drone is in the movie as well there are
all kinds of theories about them bringing him back
because mysterio is kind of like this smoke and
mirrors act that can actually be used by william
ginter riva because he took all of mysterio's
tech in his animations with him when he bolted at
the end of that movie there is a preview of a new
doctor strange costume but it's like the weekend
chill version of his regular costume like jeans
and a t-shirt and also not really sure what he's
doing with this shovel more importantly though
he is still using the eye of agamotto even though
the time stone was atomized by thanos in present
day so it's not clear if he replaced the time
stone with something else inside his amulet there
wong's new costume also just seems like super
chill casual wear and kevin feige did confirm
that that was wang indeed fighting abomination
mortal kombat style raging a cage during the
shangshi trailer he didn't elaborate on why he's
fighting in that tournament but everyone has just
been making the same joke about him needing money
because he's always so hard up for cash apparently
gotta get that sweet sandwich money somehow even
though abomination punches right through his spell
the ned leads and mj previews aren't particularly
crazy like ned leed's is wearing a midtown high
school jacket because there will be more scenes
at midtown high during the movie technically
i believe they're supposed to be in their senior
year by the time the movie is happening but let me
know in the comments what do you think about all
of spider-man's new costumes during the movie i'm
sure they're going to be pretty badass although my
favorite right now is the black and gold suit just
because those were the official school colors
of my college so i have a particular fondness
for black and gold there's a rumor right now that
we're going to get a new venom 2 trailer next week
sometime and they might be saving the spiderman
no way home trailer for august and attaching that
to the new suicide squad movie whenever we get
all that new footage of course i'll do all the
videos for it no worries make sure you have alerts
enabled for my channel so you don't miss any of
that i'm working on a new loki episode 5 trailer
video that should post tomorrow and you can click
here for my full loki episode 4 video and click
here for my new loki post credit scene video loki
into the loki verse thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!